danach kommt die csu auf 35,85 und ja
endlich mehr demokratie in bayern
das ist eine gute nachricht leute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
endlich wieder demokratie in bayern ja
es gab auch schon die vergangenen 70
jahren eine hervorragende demokratie in
bayern aber jetzt gibt es demokratie mit
mehr als einer partei die gab es schon
vorher
und sie wissen dass die csu es
hervorragend verstanden hat auch schon
die opposition selber zu machen und auch
darin hatte das teil übertroffen
woran hat es gelegen was glauben sie
warum warum dieses ergebnis müssen sie
glaubt dass auch hier erst mal dass das
ergebnis in bayern
der zuzug von rentner in die großstädte
die unsere bayerische kultur unsere
landschaft und unser ganzes brauchtum
teilweise nur missbrauchen oder genießen
davon was möchte ich sagen
der bayerische wähler hat wahrscheinlich
gesagt mein verstand sagt nein aber mein
herz sagt auch nein
mehr ist nicht danach jetzt solche
fragen zu beantworten was soll ich sagen
mein einziger wunsch hinzu kommt der
wunsch ein absolut ja 5 stabiles bayern
aber alles gegeben was irgendwer sagen
und es hat nicht gereicht muss man sagen
ja das wird wieder
ja große überraschung in bayern gibt es
doch intelligentes leben ja intelligent
weil die csu einen klaren auftrag
bekommen hat bayern stabil zu halten das
problem ist ja nur weil man kreuz
pflicht verordnet heißt das natürlich
nicht automatisch dass der wähler auf
das kreuz an der richtigen stelle machen
müssen er ist ein macher markus söder r
drückt auf die tube
für die beliebtheitswerte die ähren drei
monaten hat brauchte angela merkel drei
amtszeiten auch was wert
da sie wissen auch dass markus söder nur
sehr begrenzte zeit hatte der mich nur
sechs monate als ministerpräsident aber
dafür war sehr schnell sehr ungewiss das
ist unglaublich für jeden prozentpunkt
im zentrum heute bekommen hat könnte ich
ein schnaps mit ihnen trinken und immer
noch laufen ich nicht sie ließen etwas
probieren war sehr trinkfest oder ja
zwangsläufig in dem job sie als party
beauftragter der csu egal die sieges
party sieht anders aus oder ja also ich
könnte der nächste smart die nicht
kommen wenn sie mal richtige party geht
man fällt die haben schon noch mal wir
könnten hier war stark wie im westen
[Musik]
seehofer
herr seehofer ich wollte mich noch ich
freue mich noch verabschieden wenn wir
beim nächsten parteitag schnell
wiedersehen war schulzeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]